Traduttore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Salve a tutti.
Io farò, in questi minuti,
un elogio della collaborazione.
L'elogio è un discorso in cui si decantano
le virtù di qualcosa o di qualcuno.
Ecco, qui non c'è una persona
di cui io parlerò.
Non c'è neanche un oggetto,
È qualcosa di immateriale ma concreto
dentro di noi perché la sentiamo.
Perché è un processo sociale,
la collaborazione.
È un modo di interagire
con le altre persone.
Stamattina l'abbiamo sentita citare,
fra l'altro, ecco.
La particolarità è questa:
che viviamo, noi tutti,
un’epoca in cui alleniamo solo una,
diciamo, delle nostre due braccia, no?
Ecco, usate questa immagine.
Uno dei nostri due muscoli.
E quello che alleniamo di più
è il braccio, è il muscolo
dell'individuo e della competizione.
Quindi, farò un elogio
della collaborazione,
per dire che abbiamo bisogno
di allenare anche un'altra parte,
perché è meglio quando le due braccia
sono ben bilanciate.
Viviamo un'epoca in cui siamo
continuamente sollecitati,
appunto, ad allenare una parte.
Il fatto di vivere
in una società individualista
non è di per sé una cosa brutta.
Anzi, vorrei togliere,
se me lo concedete,
quel sapore moralistico
dalla parola ‘individualista’.
Perché è una parola
che ci richiama qualcosa di negativo,
come se fosse qualcosa di brutto
già appunto a sentirlo dire,
e spesso è utilizzato così.
Ecco, io vorrei togliere questo sentore
e usarlo in termini sociologici.
Tant'è che c'è proprio
un sociologo francese contemporaneo,
che si chiama Alain Ehrenberg, che dice:
"Noi viviamo in una società
sociologicamente individualista",
nel senso che è un momento storico,
un'epoca, in cui conta molto di più
l'individuo della collettività.
E questa, di per sé,
non è una cosa brutta.
È stata una conquista.
Una conquista del Rinascimento,
dell'Umanesimo.
Tutti noi abbiamo molta più cura di noi.
Siamo molto più attenti
a ciò che ci fa felici,
a ciò che ci piace,
quindi siamo profondamente 'individuati'.
Quindi l'individualismo è un tratto
della società contemporanea,
e non è detto che l'individualismo
sia di per sé ‘egoismo’.
Noi possiamo essere individualisti,
nel senso di aver cura di noi,
e altruisti.
Le due cose stanno insieme,
non vanno separate.
Questo è importante,
sennò ci areniamo.
Quindi, dobbiamo attraversare
questi confini, queste categorie.
Viviamo in una società così.
È anche una società
in cui prevale la competizione.
Anche questa non vorrei metterla
in termini moralistici.
Io ho sempre amato lo sport,
mi piace competere.
È bello l'elemento della competizione
perché ti tira fuori il meglio di te.
Ti induce a tirar fuori il meglio di te.
Ecco, semplicemente vorrei elogiare
qualcosa che c'è un po' meno
in una società in cui c'è molto questo,
di cui sappiamo anche
i costi di tutto ciò:
il costo dell'individualismo,
come quando ogni cosa diventa 'troppo',
diventa ipertrofica
come quegli organi che si gonfiano,
è la solitudine, l'angoscia di vivere,
il male di vivere.
Uno dei grandi miti dell'individualismo,
come felicità individuale,
è ritrovarsi soli con sé stessi.
Quindi abbiamo bisogno
di allenare l'altra parte,
quella che parla di collaborazione
e di solidarietà, impegno con gli altri.
Ma com’è fatta esattamente
la collaborazione?
Che cos'è che ha?
Che cos'è che ha
di interessante per noi?
La collaborazione è un processo sociale
che avviene con altri.
Non lo facciamo da soli.
E quindi possiamo uscire
dall'individualismo come 'individui'
ma anche dall'individualismo
come ‘organizzazioni’.
Io lavoro in campo sociale
e cerco, diciamo,
di facilitare il fatto
che più persone, più organizzazioni
possano cooperare, collaborare.
Perché? Perché questo?
Non perché è giusto in sé,
ma perché è più efficace.
Perché abbiamo problemi
sociali contemporanei,
sfide che appunto abbiamo davanti a noi,
per cui ci serve quello che,
tanti anni fa, un filosofo
- alcuni anni fa avveniva
la nascita di internet -
un filosofo francese, Pierre Levy,
chiamava ‘intelligenza collettiva’,
cioè l'affermazione,
molto ben sintetizzata,
che "nessuno sa tutto,
ognuno sa qualcosa."
Quindi, quando abbiamo di fronte a noi
un problema complesso,
l'approccio individualista,
cioè fatto di una singola persona
o di una singola organizzazione
o anche di una singola professione -
dal riscaldamento climatico
alla denatalità, al traffico,
ai problemi sociali, alla povertà -
una sola intelligenza,
una sola disciplina non ci basta.
Non è sufficiente,
ci serve l'intelligenza collettiva.
Quindi abbiamo bisogno
che queste cose dialoghino.
E come avviene?
Avviene sostanzialmente
con cinque ingredienti di questo cocktail,
diciamo, di questo mix.
La prima è una qualità intensa di ascolto.
La collaborazione si nutre dell'attesa
del punto di vista dell'altro.
Quindi, dobbiamo attraversare il confine
del nostro io e decentrarci.
Secondo elemento fondamentale
per un’esperienza collaborativa
è il fatto di approssimarsi
a un punto di vista diverso,
tentando di armonizzare gli interessi,
che vanno mantenuti diversi.
Perché il rischio è che noi riusciamo
a collaborare
solo con coloro
che la pensano come noi.
Ma la vera sfida della collaborazione
è quella di, appunto,
collaborare con chi è diverso da noi.
Per far questo c'è un tempo dell'attesa.
L'altro deve entrare dentro di noi.
L'altro come punto di vista,
come visione del mondo.
Il terzo ingrediente è la tolleranza.
Abbiamo bisogno di legittimare
l'esistenza di un punto di vista 'altro'.
E anche di tollerarla,
anche in termini cognitivi.
Sopportare il rumore,
il fastidio di un'idea dissonante.
Ecco, se noi riusciamo a reggere l'idea
- appunto, questo fastidio -
riusciamo a entrare in contatto,
anche ad attraversare i confini
dei nostri schemi culturali,
dei nostri modi di vedere il mondo
con cui siamo stati educati
ed entrare in contatto verso un altro.
Il quarto ingrediente è il coordinamento
di azioni e di attenzioni.
Perché la collaborazione,
sentite la parola,
è soprattutto un’azione.
Non è qualcosa che diciamo di fare,
è qualcosa che riusciamo a fare.
E quindi il fare, l'azione
è il banco di prova della collaborazione.
E come funziona questa azione?
Ecco funziona come una danza.
La collaborazione è un’interazione
in cui ci sincronizziamo,
come hanno fatto i musicisti prima
o come avviene con un'orchestra
o con una danza a due, come nel tango.
C'è una sincronizzazione
di menti e di corpi.
Tutti noi l’abbiamo sperimentata,
quindi sono sicuro che dico qualcosa che,
appunto, in parte vi risuona.
Ma la vera sfida
è quella di riuscire a farlo
con quelli con cui ci viene meno facile.
Ed è una fatica, tendenzialmente,
ben ricompensata,
perchési scopre il ‘nuovo’,
si inventa altro, si produce bellezza,
si sta meglio in una coppia,
in una famiglia,
in una organizzazione,
in un ambiente di lavoro, in una comunità,
se riusciamo a compensare questo eccesso
di individualismo e di competizione,
mitigandone gli aspetti meno nobili
e andando a rafforzare
questo aspetto collaborativo.
Da ultimo, quinto elemento,
quinto ingrediente, ecco,
è che la collaborazione
può essere facilitata se
l'ambiente in cui si realizza,
la cultura, l'organizzazione la legittima
da un punto di vista formale.
Noi abbiamo la Costituzione.
La nostra Costituzione è la legge
da questo punto di vista.
È una Costituzione che dice queste cose.
Ma anche le piccole
costituzioni quotidiane,
quelle del modo in cui
funziona la nostra famiglia,
in cui si collabora a fare le cose.
O del nostro gruppo di amici
in cui si collabora,
o anche nel mondo del lavoro.
Ci sono delle aziende che l’han capita
talmente tanto bene che mitigano,
mitigano proprio con le regole
gli eccessi della competizione
perché sono ‘anti-produttivi’,
non sono efficaci.
Quindi, la collaborazione,
da questo punto di vista,
è anche conveniente,
è anche un vantaggio competitivo.
Potremmo usare questo paradosso:
se un’organizzazione riesce a collaborare
riesce a competere meglio
con le altre organizzazioni.
Pensate alle piccole aziende italiane,
che sono molto piccole e frammentate,
si usa dire che serve una cultura
della collaborazione, di rete,
fare sistema,
sono queste le espressioni.
Quindi, questo è appunto l’elogio
che volevo fare.
L’invito, un po’ ad esercitare
questa cosa nella nostra vita,
nella nostra vita personale e lavorativa.
Perché di questo c'è, credo,
ci sia un gran bisogno.
Ultimo ingrediente,
ultima cosa che mi sento di dire,
da questo punto di vista è l'attitudine,
proprio, a questa cultura collaborativa.
Qual è l'elemento che possiamo riassumere
in un motto, che è questo:
"Non collaborare solo
se l'altro collabora."
Molte persone usano questa espressione:
"Ma io collaborerei col mio vicino,
il mio collega, il mio vicino di casa,
con l'altra realtà, l'altra azienda
se lui, se lei, se loro collaborassero!"
Chi studia come me
la collaborazione da molti anni,
e ha dentro questi processi,
sa che la collaborazione funziona
per anticipazione.
Quindi, il motto qual è?
Se vuoi collaborare,
devi ragionare in questo modo:
collabora tu affinché l'altro collabori.
Quindi, dai tu il primo spazio.
Apri tu la danza.
E tanti studi nelle neuroscienze
ci dicono, fin dalla prima infanzia,
che chi apre i giochi collaborativi ha una
buona probabilità di avere poi un gioco,
appunto, collaborativo come risposta.
Grazie per l'attenzione.